en france on ne peut pas vraiment parler
d'invasion puisque la démarche est
totalement pacifique mais des milliers
de britanniques viennent s'installer
chez nous et goûte la douceur de vivre
version française le problème c'est que
les commerçants ne sont pas toujours
adaptés à ses nouveaux clients
c'est la raison pour laquelle chaque
mois à tulle les serveurs de restaurants
sont placés en situation d'immersion
totale
ils ont appris à dire truffe cai ont
saisi et confie en anglais muriel la
saga nicolas aubert ce qu'il est au off
chouchoute ce tweet sommes bien au coeur
de la corrèze plus précisément dans le
restaurant du centre d'apprentissage de
tulle
jupp heynckes ces jeunes se destinent
tous un métier de serveur
ce jour là l'exercice est
particulièrement difficile interdiction
de parler français
de toute façon les invités sont presque
tous en gris fred chanterelles
chanterelles je crois qu'elle n'a même
pas compris la question parce que je
tente robbins déjà fait une assiette
comme s'il vous plaît pensez vous pouvez
pratiquer votre métier est en danger
aujourd'hui non non le jeu sera vendu ce
quinté
réputé bon départ sert à l'angleterre
les anglais sont tous résidents
permanents corrèze une fois par mois ils
viennent déjeuner receipts gratuitement
pour eux c'est aussi une façon de
s'intégrer
nous voulons nous intégrer c'est c'est
très facile et les gens abena où nous
habitons ils ont très très très
accueillante débriefing avec le prof
d'anglais
chacun a vaincu sa peur c'est aussi tout
l'intérêt de l'expérience redonner
confiance à des jeunes souvent en échec
scolaire
comment alors montré que avec le bagage
qu'ils ont dû peuvent franchir la
barrière de la communication et ma foi
converser les jeunes que vous avez
aujourd'hui le font ils le font avec
leurs mots le font avec leurs moyens
mais ils le font d'autres six essais et
également les personnels de
l'établissement pour eux une remise à
niveau à l'aide de jeux de rôle ou
passeport ce qui est difficile en fait
c'est lorsqu'on nous interroge un manque
de vocabulaire
donc il faut un peu de temps pour
chercher les frères l'expérience
poursuivra à la rentrée prochaine
en attendant et comme on dit en corrèze
désormais good luck à tous ces jeunes